you guys ready okay let's go ahead and
get started I want to welcome everyone
to our demise Thursday research
conference and on some of these
conferences we sort of have special
conferences so the today is one of those
days the informatics discovery lab which
is headed up by dr. Aaron Cohen one of
our faculty who actually is
unfortunately way out of town at a
conference can't be here today but will
be hearing today about one of the major
projects of the IDL which is their work
with the night cardiovascular institute
in helping to develop a data analytics
capability and we'll have four
presenters who I'll introduce in a
moment but first I have some
housekeeping one is for either people
who are here physicians who are either
here or listening online and one
continuing medical education cme credit
will Lynn will be sending out a survey
monkey link so people can sign up to get
that CME credit and i also want to just
announce some upcoming dates X a week
from today our speaker will be dr. vinay
prasad from the knight Cancer Institute
he's if you've read about him you've
read it like in the New York Times
whatever he's done a lot of interesting
work around conflict of interest in
clinical trials and things like that so
he'll be here next week I would be
remiss if I didn't remind everyone about
October 28 and actually the 27th for the
fellows dr. patty Brennan the new
director of the National Library
medicine is coming out will be the BIC
will be celebrating all day and the
28th our 25th anniversary of the
building some of us were here then and
some of the originator 'he's the people
who got the BIC when it was a center
started will be here in speaking dr. Don
limburg who was the director of the NLM
for many years and and then the keynote
talk will be patty Brennan and starting
at one o'clock in the afternoon and then
there's actually going to be an open
house all through the building and so
everyone is invited to attend and
there's also i heard a good speaker on
november third but i'll let you guys
figure out who that is anyways let me
introduce our speakers today dr. Mudds
not here okay so i'll start with the
rest and i'm only going to read this
briefly because if I read everything
they sent me you wouldn't get to hear
their talk so first we'll hear from Greg
lampros who's the clinical department
administrator for the night
cardiovascular institute and has been
working with our team Aaron and Nicole
weisskopf well mentioned in a moment to
develop this data analytics capability
for cardiovascular care which is an
important priority of the night
cardiovascular institute he's also part
of the night cardiovascular institute
executive clinical leadership team
manages cardiology clinics and outreach
services and a number of other functions
he will be joined in this talk by
anindita Bochy Santa close enough it was
a systems application analyst in the
clinical informatics department in the
hospital and works primarily on night
cardiovascular institute projects and
then the third presenter will be our own
dr. Nicole weisskopf was an assistant
professor in the department and is
involved in the night cardiovascular
proud
and also as an interest in data quality
and if he comes we'll also hear from dr.
James mud who's an assistant professor
associate professor of medicine in the
division of cardiology and director of
the heart transplant and advanced
cardiac services program so I will not
take up any more time of our speakers so
you need to put this on it's mostly on
for capturing as we don't really need a
microphone so we'll be a little bit out
of order I was totally supposed to be
second and so I'll just run down to my
slides here and
so my background is in both the clinical
patient care and in operations and and
then I get my informatics and analytics
from a career in industry where I used
analytics in trading futures and
derivatives to position cash flows
against large production inventories and
back then analytics wasn't the you know
I put put my first motherboard together
you know you got him in the mail and you
press little chips in the board and
develop their own systems they aren't
used to write little programs to help
unwind and wine our positions but the
Chicago Mercantile was probably pretty
futuristic and that we could have a
number of monitors on our desk and we
could watch the market move in real time
that was back in the 80s when that came
about I did drove my first graph v XY
axis with a quadratic equation when I
was a senior in undergrad school and my
time you had to take the class in a
slide rule of your science major and I
was really good with that at one time I
can't even add or subtract on it now but
one time I was pretty good so I go way
back in in how data is used in
mathematics and things such as that and
so for me or what I brought to the table
is the visualization of data since I
sort of where I cut my teeth and
predictive analytics used to build some
predictive analytics programs back in
the early 80s that would predict market
trends and and future positions of the
commodities that we had to deal with
based on political economic and social
reforms that we had happened in the past
and we thought were currently in place
in the future and we use those models
quite a bit in our trading decisions so
we use data to make decisions and so
when I came to healthcare I didn't see a
lot of that going on I didn't see the
data within medicine was being used in
that type of manner where we would
visualize the data
predict outcomes and the market started
to change not too long after I got here
about nine years ago in that the
government and currently what the
Affordable Care Act had just happened a
few years ago started to put more
pressure on institutions to reduce their
costs and improve their quality and so
they came out with a number of programs
and let me just skip to that real quick
and these are called these are some of
the names of the Macra is the newest one
bundled payments population health you
may have heard of and value-based
purchasing so value-based purchasing was
one of the first and that was mainly the
payers we're going to purchase the value
of your outcomes are other words they're
trying to make sure that you had improve
your patient outcomes and met certain
metrics that you could prove that you
were providing better health care and if
you did then they would reward you
accordingly either with a positive
increase in your payment or a negative
decrease in your deduction so the
objective of this was to I shouldn't say
push but Luke physicians and healthcare
systems into a new world of financial
accountability for quality and cost for
patients they care for and the newest
macro is sort of i would say bundling a
lot of this together but what macra is
doing is it offers multiple pathways
with pay verifying levels of risk and
reward for providers to to tie more of
their payments to quality so instead of
just fee for service you're going to be
paid more on your quality outcomes and
how how you improve actually the overall
health care your patients but you need
data to do that you need metrics to
present to show that that happens so
that in this system the physicians are
scored on four metrics quality is one
which is what we're talking about today
resource use clinical practice
improvement activities and meaningful
use of the EHR electronic medical record
of technology and then based on those
you can earn as much as a nine percent
in synon are as low as a nine percent
deduct
your payments from CMS so with this
changing landscape would also have
bundled payments which means that if a
patient comes in the hospital for 90
days after no matter where they go after
you're accountable for their care so
even if they're admitted to another
hospital if they're admitted to a rehab
unit where that bundled payment says
here's so much money to take care of
this patient for the next 90 days
whatever happens to them you're
accountable for that care and the cost
of that care just there's a lot more to
it than that but just quickly population
health which is where this analytics
really comes into play and what we've
done is part of that bundle payment
where we can actually start to manage
population not just within ohsu but
across the system and across the state
so that we're actually improving the
health care of all oregonians and not
just those who come to ohsu so their
goals are clear and organizational focus
around quality safety and service which
I've someone mentioned optimization of
outcomes through standardization and
efficiency cultural integration among
providers which which right now is
including the cultural transformation
this is a lot to add on to providers
plates from what they've already had
added on and just defining these for
example the Mac or documents almost a
thousand pages the government's really
good at making big thick documents to
explain what they couldn't about five
pages but that's how big it is and etc
and and of course expectation of clarity
of purpose and expected outcomes which
is again where analytics comes into play
so our objective and with this project
is the standardized heart failure care
so we focused on that disease there's a
number him but it was heart failure we
started with at and beyond ohsu and we
want to move beyond just treating heart
failure to building an analytics
architectural platform that can set the
goals build the plan designed the
workflow and communicate results that
can meet the demands of value-based
purchasing health care market one of the
things that started this was a few years
ago dr. blocking cigarroa came to me and
we were just starting with this program
called Meaningful Use at that time and
we're getting certain metrics and he was
looking at his data that I'd sent him
and
showed that based on a metric around
aspirin and providing aspirin as the
therapy for patients who have had a
myocardial infarction his was not a
hundred percent and he said that can't
be I always do it all the time it's a
hundred percent and if not there's a
reason why so he asked me to look into
the data and we couldn't really find why
the other piece wasn't there only that
he met a certain percent and so we
started to look further into and he said
well we need to take a disease state and
look at the whole disease state and see
what the metrics are that we required
which at the time with the American
College of Cardiology metrics which
there is nine metrics and how we perform
against them because of what was coming
down the road and all these new demands
that are coming from the government
payers are lining up behind them and
they're saying if you don't meet these
metrics we're not going to pay you for
all your services and so we needed a way
to say to the payers this is why we're
not a hundred percent use of aspirin for
this certain condition there's reasons
not if you're on another blood thinner
you went prescribe absolute asking for
example and so we started to think about
this there's another person in our
department year is cleaner who's a PhD
software engineer and he and I got
together and started to pull data and
found out that we needed a lot more
brainpower and support than what we just
the two of us could do together his
brain power is a lot bigger than mine
but I certainly needed a lot of support
and so we got together with de maiz and
developed a collaboration between us to
look at these metrics and find a way to
source the data validate the data and
then put together a visual graphing
program that was real time and could
provide our providers with the
information they knew to see how they
were doing on these nine metrics now we
focused on outpatient because in
patients a little easier to do this
nationally sixty-seven percent of
patient patients when they leave the
hospital there's documentation that
they're meeting these metrics on the
outpatient side though which is most of
their world only twenty-seven percent is
documented that they're beaten Vic the
guidelines that are set aside by the
American College of Cardiology so that's
where we focus because we needed to show
payers and CMS that we were meeting
these metrics across the system not just
impatient but outpatient and as we go
forward across the state and so this
type of work has to move into more with
our partners like Salem tuality we're
working with mid-columbia on some of
these things and up in the dowels and so
that we can show that our patients that
come to ohsu and that are in our system
are getting the proper patient quality
care so I guess I could go back a little
bit and talk about dr. Mudds piece on
this like not as eloquent as he is on it
that he's on rounds in the hospital
right now he's probably caught up with
some patients but as he noted
well-intended healthcare teams can
become overburdened with a complex
system and unintentionally delivered
substandard care and we know that I
tronic causes of death or but if you're
to line it up as a disease state it
falls under heart heart disease as
number one cancers number two and it
would be number three in the number of
deaths and so it's a big concern with
the health care system and as he noted
it's often due to the complexities of it
of the health care system and overload
of actual data streams and so what he
wanted to look at is how can we best
leverage the EHR to identify patients
and deliver guideline recommended
quality and value driven patient care
which is what this project is about he
noted that in the US 6.6 million adults
have heart failure there's 875,000
diagnosed at with the age / 45 1.8
million office visits and 22
in and that's gone way up since to 2016
and over a 1 million hospitalizations
annually from 2002 2010 twenty-five
percent of those are readmitted within a
month and fifty percent are readmitted
within six months so these are multiple
readmissions one of the metrics for
Medicare is that if a patient has a
diagnosis of heart failure and leaves
leaves the hospital and returns within
30 days we pay the bill they won't pay
for that with the idea that we were
supposed to do better in their follow-up
care after they left the hospital so if
they didn't return so you're not going
to prevent all of them from returning
but again we've used data to track
length of stay and another number of
other measures their risk assessment and
their case makes index etc to determine
and documentation what we need to do to
make sure we're following up and some of
these are again came from visual
analytics and we've hired different
people because of what the analytics
have shown who doubt now set more in a
transition phase to make sure the
patients are following up with their
appointments and that the care
management is being appropriate given to
them in their homes and their return to
the clinic a lot of them get lost they
don't return the clinic and where they
return is the emergency room then they
end up in the hospital where a lot of
their conditions can be evaluated and
taking care of prior to that happening
so it's a 30 point seven billion total
cost for heart failure 69 billion in
20-30 for cardiovascular care in total
that stroke etc and the vascular system
the estimate is that it will cost this
nation 1.2 trillion in 20 30 at
healthcare costs that's up from 287
billion in 2010 so it's a it's a real
issue in our population it's a Western
disease so to speak and it's something
that we have to get our arms around as a
nation because the costs that are
associated and it's the most common
cause admissions of patients over 65 and
the largest contributor to 17 billion
spent for unplanned readmissions so
these are emissions that weren't planned
and to come back to the emergency room
there's a thirty-five percent survival
five years after a hospitalization
independent of the ejection fraction and
this chart shows over time the survival
that what dr. Mudd would point out is
that once you're diagnosed with heart
failure that's a lifelong condition
there you get recovered through that
with a heart transplant they have
certainly left ventricular device or L
VADs that will keep the heart working
until transplant or what we call bridge
to transplant but once you're it it's a
is a disease that's there and unlike
many types of cancer that are curable
and you may not ever go back into
readmission this one's there and all the
main thing that the medicines do now
make it so it's more livable for the
patient and they can live a more
productive life than what they used to
do so that's where medicine is taken at
this for so it's quite a concern and if
there's those of you who are physicians
you can correct me if I'm wrong on some
of this guilt free to this is the
projected cost as he talked about you
can see the prevalence from twenty ten
to twenty thirty is up twenty five
percent but the direct cost from the
same time revise two hundred fifteen
percent so that's what is costing the
nation or will cause division the
quality metrics that we looked at on the
outpatient I mentioned 9 there was six
that we primarily focused on stage and
functional classification systolic
function assessment that was a really
difficult one on a databases to acquire
and validate get a lot of chart review
Nicola her team and symptom assessment
and management patient self care
education medication prescription and
counseling about implantable devices the
patient self care education is a really
important one and if we look at a heat
map we can see all our patients
individually their appointments into the
future and we can see whether they're
meeting these guidelines or not that's a
heat map we've developed fisa Khan has
developed that heat map who's part of
our team
and so we're able and what we've seen
the the red the reddest part of the heat
map is red and green is inpatient self
education and implantable device
counseling and we found out as the
patient that can care for themselves the
best that are the most educated that
have the best outcomes with heart
failure are with truly with any any
disease and so we're able to then look
at the heat map and get hold of these
patients in and have a caseworker start
to work with them on make sure they're
educated on how to take care of their
disease proactively so I'm not sure what
this one is
so this is a very simple example of the
kind of patient that might come to ohsu
for heart failure treatment he's here
for his second appointment which is when
a lot of these quality metrics kick in
and he was diagnosed with heart failure
by his primary care provider who also
started him on a beta-blocker due to his
reduce systolic function which is
appropriate but in this specific case he
was prescribed a beta blocker that is
not actually one of the evidence-based
medications so what the ohsu provider
would want to do at this point is get
them onto one of the evidence-based
medications but it can be difficult to
we need to find better ways to present
that information to the provider and
make sure that it's actionable okay
right so as some of the thing but letís
put up or what phase of the disease or
are they in are they receiving the
correct interventions and how can we
leverage the EHR to make clinical actual
and usable and then monitor it over time
which was part of our project so why
does standardization matter consistent
application of evidence-based therapies
and here's dr. blood right now so I have
rolled into your part of your
presentation so I'll you I can you can
come and go ahead I'll show you you can
see up there as far as I have got cotton
yep I'm very sorry so I'm Jim madam
director the heart failure and heart
transplant program here and this has
been a great journey together for this
so the challenge is that we as
clinicians are sort of we get hamstrung
by a lot of things and we think we're
doing the right thing but we don't
always necessarily document it in the
right manner and what happened is we
have well intentioned systems but the
poorly executed sometimes and it's
because sometimes we fight epic and we
shouldn't really be fighting epic we
should embrace epic and use it to the
advantage of the teams and the patients
so there's complexities of the system
there's really lots of
data none dated with data and the
question is how to get actionable data
so how can we leverage the electronic
health record to identify the patients
who have the disease of interest or the
condition of interest and how do we
deliver the therapies that they need so
hard flair is a test case we'll
hearthfire is a problem and this is some
of the stats that may be great one
through and the thing that we focus a
lot on other readmissions 25%
readmission within one month and fifty
percent at six months and the reason
that's a big issue from readmission
standpoint okay I'm sorry well I can
talk about you go station functional
class Greg okay so if we look at a
patient here we don't necessarily know
what therapies they are getting and the
question is are we getting the right
therapies at the right time what stage
the disease are they in and how can we
monitor them over time and how can we
make the electronic health record
clinically actionable and useful to be
able to deliver the therapies that they
need and how do we monitor to them over
time through various clinical encounters
and through various providers because
not one provider or team of providers is
seeing for these patients all the time
it's multiple providers in sub specialty
or in primary care so the reason that
this is important is because a lot of
times we think we're doing the right
thing but we may not necessarily be
doing the right thing we're pretty good
with the electronic health record and
documenting medications but that doesn't
necessarily mean medication adherence
similarly we are not able to document
some discrete variables that are
clinically meaningful outside of
medications the nice thing about
medications is it's there it gets pulled
in that doesn't mean the patients taking
it just means you've prescribed it two
very different things we still no
medication adherence for example a year
after myocardial infarction is only
about sixty to seventy percent of the
medications that we know that having
improved morbidity mortality so clicking
buttons and prescribing things doesn't
necessarily mean patients are taking it
but if we have a better way to monitor
it hopefully we can work on medication
adherence with various team members and
this hopefully will lead to improve
morbidity and mortality and decrease the
hospitalizations that again are a large
part of that
teen billion dollars that is spent on
readmissions and importantly then you
can resource the system a little bit
better one of the problems in medicine
is we put we plug patients into the
system but maybe not when they need to
be seen and conversely we're not seeing
the people that we need to be seen so
how can we use the electronic medical
record and the provisions of that to get
the right patient to the right provider
at the right time Andrey appropriate
resources we have a lot of resources
that we think are efficient but it's
just a lot of waste in the system and we
have to be able to be better with that
so we need to know what's already been
done we need to find out what needs to
be done and we need to limit that
documentation verted and we need to have
document in a discoverable manner right
now we do we've employed dragon
dictation throughout the institution
which I personally like it's a great way
of really being able to give a lot more
dialogue to the care that you're
delivering and the care that teams
delivering the challenges it's not
necessarily easily discoverable you can
do the and you'll know this better than
I do that natural language processing
and hunt for things but there are
certain things we shouldn't have to hunt
for we should just open it up as a bin
of ones and zeros and download it right
away and we don't necessarily do that so
that's the flip side I think of having
dragon dictation across the institution
so we want to be able to have important
salient features to the clinical
encounter be able to be discoverable in
a quick manner greg did you go for some
of this again i apologize
ok so the informatics side of this is
going to be split into two sections so
I'll be handing this off halfway through
to anindita so let's return to our
simple clinical example and the question
for us is in fermentations is how can we
leverage the EHR and other health
information technology to help this
patient and also patients like him so
one thing we want to make sure that
providers are able to tell if this
specific patient is receiving
appropriate care we want to know
providers in general are following
evidence-based standards of care and
lastly we want to actually use health
information technology to not just
provide information but to actually help
providers improve the quality of care at
the individual and the population level
so this is our picture of how we would
like things to work so this would be
performance on one of these clinical
quality measures and the idea is that
over time through various interventions
we are able to take performance all the
way up to this maximum benchmark which
ideally would be a hundred percent
sometimes that's not totally feasible
but what we know from past research and
also our own experience is that there is
a pretty big difference for some of
these measures between observed
performance and actual performance and a
lot of that is due to limitations and
the data that we can access in the
systems that we're using so before we
can really start effectively improving
actual performance we need to bring this
observed line up to the actual line
because that way we can tell how we're
really doing and we know what we need to
address
oops so between the actual and the
maximum capable we have care related
issues we want to address but below that
are the issues due to implementation and
also data related problems so I'm not
going to go through this whole thing
because it's kind of crazy but this is
an overview of the process that we use
in the IDL when we implement and
validate a single clinical quality
measure and you can see there's work in
interpreting these measures identifying
the data sources that we need doing
system development the actual measure
development validation and then
synthesizing the results to make them
actionable for providers and also for
Anand data and her team so there's a lot
of collaboration there's a lot of
iteration and overall just a lot of work
and this is one of the things that we
get out of all this work this is a
visualization developed by FISA these
are the nine ACC heart failure measures
and this is overall performance we have
various visualizations that drill down
so this is the overall Casey VI
performance we can drill down by team we
can drill down by provider and this is a
report that is provided to decision
makers and stakeholders on a regular
basis so we've gotten that flow of
information to them but when we do that
that validation the in-depth validation
we do even though we have minimized the
problems due to implementation due to
the c qm calculation system we still
have problems with the validity and
reliability of these measures this is
kind of information overload a little
bit but the important points so this
this is the lvef measure so just has a
provider reviewed a reviewed the patient
systolic function so this is a pretty
fundamental measure for heart failure
our observed performance which is that
top left Venn diagrams about seventy two
percent based on manual chart review we
know it's actually about ninety-eight
percent so then we want to know why is
there such a difference we're doing
pretty well capturing the denominator
popular
which is based on diagnosis a number of
visits and age and then over here is the
problem this is the numerator so these
are the patients who have had their
systolic function reviewed and we are
missing a whole bunch of those people
and when we do some analysis of that
what we learn is that the combination of
factors part of it is that these lvef
values are not always structured so our
system can't get at them often that's
because these are referral patients so
they've got their systolic function in
an external report it has been reviewed
but we don't have documentation of that
another possibility is in lvef was
recorded outside the time window of
interest and a provider may have
reviewed it more recently but there's no
way to document the fact that they have
reviewed it and discussed it with the
patient so we just can't get at that
information the system can't do it so at
this point we've moved up this observed
line by getting rid of all the
implementation problems that we can but
we're still not all the way up to
matching the observed performance with
the actual performance so we still have
this bridge that needs to be closed so
we need to improve documentation and the
data related problems and we also need
to start actually working on the actual
performance and in order to do that we
need an intervention and that's where
anandita and her team came in
so I came in in the middle of this
project and I was told to improve them
information system so as dr. Matt
mentioned we wanted to have standardized
care across ohsu for heart failure
patients and wanted evidence-based
guidelines to be followed for their
treatment and then the work that I deal
had done to it showed there's a
discrepancy between what's actually
happening about like in the chart review
shows it's a 90 something percent that
this documentation but when you do the
automatic automatic data extract and
quality measures it's much lower so for
us in clinical informatics we follow the
standard sdlc process of system
development life cycle of doing an
analysis of what's currently there
what's the gap and how do we get to our
ideal state so when we looked at the
current process we saw that it was data
was being entered in as free text which
is not ideal for you know writing
queries and logics and extracting the
data and a simple tool was being used
called dot phrase I'm going to use a lot
of epic terminology I I don't know
whether you're familiar with it but stop
me if you need to know more so uh from
there we needed to get to our vision of
standardized care and evidence-based
guidelines for these patients and so we
looked at what what are the gaps so the
current tool had limited capability
because it depended on the providers
remembering to use it and it was not
capturing all the discrete data elements
that were needed for the quality
measures it was also a lack of
standardized workflow for these kind of
patients and guidelines for that and we
also didn't have any method for doing a
decision support guidance for these
patients so in our planning phase and I
think this is very important we collect
there was a lot of collaboration we like
dr. Matt he wanted everybody at a wait
to see whether it's especially subs
other sub specialists or primary care
physicians looking at it to follow the
same guidelines so heart failure has a
best practice committee which is a
multidisciplinary committee so that was
a good platform to bring it bring up
these issues and discuss what the
providers wanted and also from our side
in informatics we work very closely with
the itg group to develop the tools and
it took a whole team of people to
develop what we needed so next I'll go
over some of the tools that we built to
and why we built them and to get to our
end point so one of the things is that
we want this documentation tool to be
available to all providers and take care
of variations and practice start with
documentation practice and the way the
patient enters the system I mean the
patient can be just inpatient or
outpatient and the various differences
so we leverage the use of the epic
registry so we've created a database we
check the inclusion rule and modify the
inclusion rule to you know maybe look at
problem list and encounter diagnosis
these are the things that would take
care of practice variation and you know
looked at the inpatient charts and
outpatient to capture the data and have
a database for heart failure population
so this this registry was then used for
making a documentation tool in this case
whatever calls a smart form available to
the providers when the patient is in the
heart failure registry so it captures
discrete data and that's where we
plugged in all the data elements that
were needed for the quality metrics next
we built a smart
this is another way this is a way to
efficiently order some of the
evidence-based medications that are
needed for these patients and you know
for example this is the feedback that we
got from primary care that having a
smart said would really help them place
those medication orders so you know it's
really important to talk to all the end
users we put in a best practice alert to
remind the providers like hey this is
you need to fill out this form it's it's
important another piece that we did was
the synopsis synopsis is a review tools
so while the provider was in the clinic
he could go back and look at the trend
of you know how the cluster the class
and the stage of the patient had changed
over time and other information and to
tie this all together in epic what we
have is a navigator navigator is it
guides the workflow so we put all these
pieces in our navigator so that
providers didn't have to click through
various you know different things in
epic to get to it and go through it
smoothly so next I'm going to talk more
in detail about the smartphone couple of
the tools that we built and how it helps
so this is the smart forum in epic and I
don't know how that zero went into it so
we try to make it as easy for the
provider as possible so that other
providers don't like I paid and they
don't like clicking so we have this one
button the Lord patients lost saved
values that is if if someone else had
already seen the patient the provider
could go click that it would fill in all
the previous values and then he only
would lead to he or she would only need
to change the ones that had changed it
for that encounter then we also have
some questions related to medication for
these we put in the program so that it
would auto populate be
the medication less like and if the
provider already prescribed the
medication it would say yes and only if
it's a no with the provider need to go
in and fill in the reasons why the
medication was not appropriate for this
patient and the providers also developed
documentation about the standard
algorithms that need to be followed for
these patients so those blue links that
you see if you click on them they tell
you you know the medication and the
dosage and extra information that would
help someone who's not very familiar
with these kind of patients what they
need to do this is an example of a smart
set so here as you can see be in the
blue you've written like some guidelines
of when you should order or not out of
these medications and some default
dosages and standard doses dosages
already pre-populated for these
medications so the provider just has to
click that and order and it'll be done
quickly so we did a whole bunch of stuff
as you can see built a lot of tools and
also for fancy things and now we want to
know whether we really made a difference
so how do we know that so I think Nicole
will tell you because she looked up at
data
okay so this is a a trend of the
performance on one of the quality
measures and this is specifically the
patient's health care education measure
and I know that was mentioned earlier as
being particularly important patients
ability and knowledge to deal with their
own care is especially predictive of
outcomes so up until this point this was
using the original clinical quality
measure that we implemented using the
existing data sources and before all of
the interventions that were just
described this first line here is when
the new tools went live specifically for
the heart failure to heart failure team
and you'll see that we split into two
different lines there in that blue one
on the bottom we kept running that's
using just the original data sources so
just the dot phrase and the red one is
using the dot phrase and the new data
coming in from the the smart form and
the related tools the second dashed red
line is when this set of tools went live
for all of cardiology not all of our
figures look quite this nice but I think
that this is really a pretty impressive
demonstration of the impact that you can
have with health information technology
when it is implemented in a really
thoughtful way and is done with
collaboration and input from a
multidisciplinary team and we expect
that this blue line is going to keep
trending downward even as the red one
continues to go up as people use the dot
phrase less and less frequently and that
gradually washes out of our measurement
window and the performance hasn't
plateaued yet we would like it to keep
getting higher and we're going to have
to see what happens especially as this
tool becomes more broadly available
so we had a number of lessons learned in
the course of doing this project and if
you guys want to pipe in for any of
these feel free so I know anindita made
this point that we need collaboration
between specialists and generalists at
the provider level and then also between
providers and informations and other
analysts in order to really ensure that
providers are going to engage with these
tools and use them instead of this just
being something that we dumped out into
the ether and it never gets used
requires a lot of feedback and focus on
actually changing practice patterns but
the good news with all of this as you
can actually optimize information
systems to meet documentation needs and
I really want to emphasize this because
a common complaint with electronic
health records is that people just
document and they document in the
document and that information is not
presented to the providers in an
actionable way a lot of the time so the
way you know what anindita was showing
with the data that will populate from
previous entry and kind of summarize the
patient state right there at the point
of care that's really unique and it's a
really powerful tool so again we need to
keep in mind the behavior of the end
user when we're designing these tools we
also learned that validation and testing
even though they're incredibly
time-consuming this manual chart review
takes a long time it's very very
important for reliability and
trustworthiness and if the providers
don't trust the data if the stakeholders
don't trust the data then it's not worth
very much we also learned that ongoing
maintenance as a resource drain but
really necessary and if you were here
for Adam rights presentation he talked
about how they would put in these
clinical decision support systems that
would suddenly break because something
in the system change somewhere we have
the same experience we've had things
were you know motoring along just fine
and then we look at the data and we're
like oh something changed there someone
changed a code and an epic or something
along those lines and lastly that tool
choice and design impacts documentation
so we're really you can change provider
behavior so we view this as success so
we had the ultimate goal of improving
clinical outcomes we developed robust
analytics tools in a reporting platform
for clinical quality measurement and you
know it's too early to look at actual
clinical outcomes but we believe that we
have improved evidence-based quality of
care we have leveraged the EHR to
improve adherence to clinical guidelines
we think that the system reflects
value-based purchasing and we have
emphasized cultural integration among
providers and between providers and the
rest of the people involved in this kind
of effort we have a very very large team
that's involved in this work thank you
guys and and so let me just remind
everyone that when they ask a question
to turn on the mic in front of them just
so the people who are listening and the
recording will be able to hear it it's
very interesting talk and it reminds me
why health care will never be as simple
as an iphone with all the complex data
and interaction required my question and
on the and I think it's great to you
know auto populate forms but sometimes
not not necessarily in health care but
when forms get Auto populated people
might not pay enough attention kind of
in the same way you know when you copy
in pace you might not be paying
attention to something has changed have
there
any problems or that has that been an
issue in all order people really pay
close attention when you guys
auto-populate yeah I mean that's a great
question that so much of this is just
cultural behavior and and documenting
things right we haven't shown that this
is improving clinical outcomes this
isn't proving our documentation of
things beyond medications that were much
easier to document you know I'm sort of
drinking the kool-aid so it's hard for
me you know we get a lot of pushback
from people like well I'm going to be
penalized it like this is not set up to
be a penalty this is set up based on
what a society has said as nine measures
that we think are important for care
because there's really no easy way to
document that we had a discussion about
whether or not a defibrillator was
indicated and there are so many codes
out there you can't necessarily pull out
who has a defibrillator not easily what
I personally I can speak to my personal
practice what I found is that for an
admittedly i see a biased population
that is sort of in some sense terminally
differentiated in their therapeutic
interventions so when I copy forward the
most important thing to me is what is
their functional classification and have
I address some big goal issues that that
are I will document and dictate but not
necessarily discrete if I didn't have
this so I think what we're seeing is
that and I think we can try to go down
and see how many people are clicking the
copy forward and then after you click
the copy forward are you then changing
something the beauty of the system is
that everything is time-stamped so you
can actually measure time and that's
really an important thing too so we
haven't I think necessarily looked at
that but we can't look at that but I
think from those of us in the heart
player group that are kind of living and
breathing this a bit more I don't think
it's that onerous and I don't think you
you run the risk of not addressing it
the problem with a lot of anything
copping four we copy forward stuff ad
nauseam every day here and it doesn't
get changed and so from a quality
standpoint or from a bucketed standpoint
it looks like we've checked the boxes
but we may not have addressed a large
proportion of that and there's no way to
discern that really but at least since
everything is a discrete area and once
it
gets clicked on if i'm not mistaken it's
stamped and she can actually look to see
how that has changed practice I don't
know if that answers your question
medication so the medication related
questions are looking at the medication
list so the provider has prescribed is
just pulling in that information and
then if you go back to the form you'll
see it's grayed out that means a
provider doesn't have to do anything but
then the ones which are no it comes up
with extra buttons of why you know the
provider has to fill in why the
medication wasn't prescribed and it's
highlighted yellow it can indicates that
you need to do like why it wasn't
prescribed because that's tied into the
quality metric where you have to like
now have legitimate exceptions exclusion
is to see that so that helps I think oh
I was wondering if the team can speak to
some of the challenges you faced as you
went to change behavior based on the
work that one india team did and how you
how you address those challenges in
terms of getting providers and medical
assistance and so forth to actually use
the tool yeah it's a great question i
think we're still early in the phase and
so it's hard to see how that changes
behavior so what we've done initially is
there four of us that that focus in the
heart failure clinic and and even
amongst our group that this is what we
do there is variability between the four
of us and so what we're trying to do is
give feedback reports to say this is not
penalizing you but here's where you are
not documenting and how does that change
practice an important thing about this
is this tool is designed for really a
subset of heart failure patients in some
sense those with a low ejection fraction
and we know that there's a lot of heart
failure patients that have a normal
ejection fraction or squeezing function
of the heart which have very few
evidence-based therapies and so how to
and we didn't want to do two different
smart forms and so some people are
saying well my patient falls out of this
and so we are getting in but we designed
this really for the the bell curve not
the tails the challenge with an academic
medical center is we see lots of tails
right we see a lot of the zebras but we
designed this for the horses and and
culturally that's how we're trying to
change behavior a little bit it's okay
not to fill it out you are not going to
be if you don't think it's germane to
that but I think it's still early in the
phase of this rolling it out to try to
change that behavior a little bit
yeah that's a great question so this
whole task could not have happened in
some sense without one number ejection
fraction so for years when we would read
cardiac ultrasounds in the echo lab we
would make a PDF and it would get
scanned into epic and there was no
discrete bucket for an EF so dr. hytner
in his efforts at the echo lab was able
finally to make ejection fraction a
discrete number in results review and
you can see it's up here the last
ejection fraction so which is not part
of some of those measures but we thought
it was very important so it is it is up
there and so it's auto populated from
the last echocardiogram that has been
bucketed into the results review if we
didn't have echo in the system this
would have been a lot harder to identify
patients with the ejection fraction of
less than or equal to forty percent for
which all these evidence-based therapies
are recommended so that patch from a
system standpoint and from really just
the two systems talking to each other
was really important there's lots of
data streams in this hospital every day
where the two systems are different
vendors and they don't talk everybody's
trying to get patched into epic but we
still have every single pacemaker we
have does not tak talk to epic right and
so what we do now is we scan printed
things into epic and an echo is the same
thing your first question was about yeah
so so right so a lot of those things are
they taking a certain pill at what surf
class what's their stage self-care is
really important but that was something
that was not discreetly identified
that's just one thing we pulled out but
I think you could pull almost outside of
medications so presence or absence of a
defibrillator would be very another one
that would be we show similarity because
that was not something that was easy to
pull from the system the medicines were
always easy to pull from the system we
were not routinely documenting stage
documenting New York Heart Association
class right my class too could be
somebody else's class three and vice
versa now we can see over time how does
that functional class assessment change
how do their medication dosages change
how do their medication prescriptions
change we don't have that level of data
until now
one thing that dr. Mudd which is getting
at is you know we've been talking about
these performance rates which is just
one view of the data that are being
captured at this point you know this
also allows you to we could do analytics
on different patients to show how
they're doing using all of these data so
it's not just about overall performance
based on these guidelines but the
availability of those data more
generally I think it's not for patient
is per provider group it's you know if
you had it in the hospital which floors
are doing better which are doing
differently what are the system barriers
to try to not only document but then
also ensure the next step is going
beyond documentation and ensuring that
the therapies are actually being
delivered the patients are actually
taking the medications we're actually
following up and doing the due diligence
on the other end so this is just a start
at least we cannot measure that initial
bucketing of the data
[Applause]
[Music]